[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie awesome news
Disney's CEO did a big earnings call
where he talked about their new
streaming services during that he
announced plans for Fantastic Four x-men
movies as soon as the Fox Disney deal
completes now buried within that were a
bunch of other plans that they announced
for what's going on with the streaming
service where all the content is going
to go what's going to be happening with
the Deadpool franchise so what I'll do
is I'll break down all the streaming
plans because that's happening at the
end of next year then I'll talk about
what's going on with all the characters
like all the x-men characters all the
Deadpool characters so it's all really
good news it's not quite as confusing as
it sounds if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos as you can see it's
gonna get crazy next year and we're
getting ready for that Captain Marvel
trailer really soon there is that
infinity war giveaway that's going on to
that I'll explain at the end of the
video so big stuff that's happening
first Disney is pulling all of its
content from all the streaming platforms
to its own Disney streaming service at
the end of next year so what's happening
next year is is that because Disney is
rolling out their new streaming platform
and everyone's like wait do I have to
pay for another streaming platform now
they confirmed that because they'll own
Hulu now what they'll do is they're
going to offer a bundle for a decrease
price so you'll have an opportunity to
get the Disney streaming service which
is basically going to get all of the
Disney Star Wars and Marvel content TV
shows and movies along with Hulu and the
new ESPN streaming service for a greatly
reduced price early prediction is as the
Disney's gonna offer that mega streaming
bundle for less than 25 bucks a month
the only Marvel stuff that's going to be
staying on Hulu in on Netflix is the
stuff that those networks bought like
the Marvel Netflix shows but aside from
that every piece of content movie or
television show the Disney now owns with
all their brands Star Wars Marvel the
straight-up Disney stuff that's pg-13 or
less is gonna go to the Disney streaming
service so that means that the Deadpool
movies and the Deadpool TV show that
they've been trying to get off the
ground for a little while that's gonna
go to Hulu that means that any future
r-rated film the Disney makes with their
IP is gonna go to Hulu now I don't see
Disney ever making a Star Wars r-rated
movie or a TV show so I don't think that
gonna be too much of an issue but it's
really just the exception you make first
stuff like Deadpool stuff that really
only works when he's r-rated they
already said that they're not gonna be
messing with the Deadpool Universe of
characters the Disney CEO Bob Iger said
that he's a big fan of the franchise so
they're just gonna let them continue to
do what they've been doing well the
rumor though is that they're getting
ready to film x-force later this year
and instead of just calling it x-force
they're gonna make it more like Deadpool
3 and Deadpool will be in the title like
they're gonna sell it as a straight-up
Deadpool sequel but as long as he's
r-rated you're not gonna see him
anywhere on the Disney streaming service
and I don't think that they want to
water him down by putting him in a whole
bunch of pg-13 movies that doesn't mean
that it's gonna be that way for forever
you just have to imagine that Kevin
Feige has about the next four years
worth of Marvel MCU films planned beyond
that anything can change especially with
this Fox a Disney deal the bigger news
here I think is the fact that they just
confirmed that they plan to make x-men
and Fantastic Four standalone movies
like people are just wondering are you
gonna use those characters are we gonna
see straight-up x-men films there were a
lot of rumors about what was going to
happen with Dark Phoenix because of this
deal they're going into three months of
reshoots but I think that they're just
trying to do their swan song because it
just makes sense that they recast all
those characters when Disney gets ahold
of them in a couple years you roll out
your new x-men team and it's completely
fresh and it makes sense within the
continuity of the MCU so even though I
would love to see James McAvoy and
Michael Fassbender come back you know
take it or leave it with Jennifer
Lawrence most of them have been playing
those characters for ten years at this
point meaning that they are very
expensive as actors remember we're at
about ten years in the MCU some of those
actors have gotten super expensive like
Chris Evans Robert Downey jr. Chris
Hemsworth so part of the job of like
these big franchise shifts is in sort of
clearing the board so that they don't
have insanely expensive movies before
they ever start shooting so in the way
that Incredible Hulk way back during
phase one is very much canon to the MCU
films but it feels like a very different
thing because it's Edward Norton and
Mark Ruffalo didn't come til the
Avengers it feels like a completely
separate thing that's kind of how we can
view the Foxx x-men films you could say
oh there universe you could treat it
like Logan like
logan is canon to the other x-men films
but it's also really loose with the way
it treats some of the other x-men films
within the continuity I think it's safe
to say the only character they're not
immediately going to recast within the
next couple of years is going to be Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine eventually they will
have to recast the character will get
MCU Avengers Wolverine but I don't think
that that's gonna happen for quite a
while and if Hugh Jackman
does come back it'll be for some crazy
time-travel old man Logan stuff a long
time ago he was quoted as saying that he
would love to do Wolverine in some sort
of Marvel MCU crossover moment if they
ever got the chance to do something like
that but that was before the Disney Deal
so nobody thought that that was ever
going to happen so I wouldn't hold your
breath on Hugh Jackman in a yellow
costume as part of the Avengers anytime
soon I think when we see the new
versions of the x-men and the MCU
they'll be younger versions of the
characters there was a really funny line
during Deadpool 2 where he's forming the
x-force team and he makes the joke about
finding young people that can carry the
franchise for 10 years we need to build
a [ __ ] team they need to be tough
morally flexible and young enough to
carry this franchise 10 to 12 years a
team of highly skilled [ __ ] I'm
talking about some oceans 14 [ __ ] rogue
- John Wood 3 when Marvel gets its hands
on the x-men that's kind of the thought
process that they'll be going through
like we need to have people that we can
cast they can do these x-men characters
for the next 10 years or so if things
work out I've already talked a little
bit about what Kevin Feige will probably
wind up doing when he actually is
allowed to use those characters doing
the spider-man Civil War thing where yes
you do have a solo x-men film but you
introduce a couple of those characters
in someone else's film first like in an
Avengers film or in another big a-list
film like Black Panther Fantastic Four
here's the thing like they say that
they're developing new x-men movies and
TV shows fantastic for movies and TV
shows any Fantastic Four TV show would
probably wind up being animated it'd be
a little more family-friendly it'd go on
that Disney streaming service now
everybody's seen that John Krasinski mr.
fantastic concept art like do a quiet
place you know your wife in real life
Emily Blunt playing Sue Storm like
please do just like a hardcore awesome
version of fantastic
or I think whatever they end up doing
with that movie it'll feel more in the
tone of an MCU film so like you have
certain expectations when you go to see
a Marvel film about how things are gonna
go some of them are a little bit more
serious like Civil War or Winter Soldier
some of them lean more in a comedy like
thor ragnarok or guardians of the galaxy
all those films should give you a good
idea for what the new versions of x-men
and Fantastic Four will feel like like I
said though Deadpool is the exception to
the rule he's still kind of off by
himself per what Disney CEO has said so
what will probably happen is is that
they'll make a big announcement at
comic-con next year because that'll be
July so it'll be after the deal is done
so they could say whatever they want to
like surprise look at all the new
awesome stuff we're gonna make with
these characters so yes of course it all
comes back around to Secret Wars like
that's where you stitch everything
together something like that is so big
that they would probably wait to do that
as sort of their bookend for whatever
the next phase of films is going to be
so like Avengers for infinity war are
the bookend for the last 10 years Secret
Wars with everybody on screen all the
same time together will probably be
their next big bookend but just post all
your questions and reactions in the
comments below I'm still doing that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video you may
have seen that Sony confirmed plans to
cross spider-man as a character over
with their venom franchise and all their
Sony spider-verse films so I'll do a
video explaining how that's going to go
down and what their actual plans are
later tonight click here to learn all
about that new Captain Marvel Easter Egg
that everybody spotted in infinity war
and click here to rewatch that deleted
Iron Man scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]